Let's now attempt to apply Stokes' theorem
And so over here we have this little diagram, and we have this path
that we're calling C, and it's the intersection of the plain Y+Z=2, so that's the plain that
kind of slants down like that, its the intersection of that plain
and the cylinder, you know I shouldn't even call it a cylinder
because if you just have x^2 plus y^2 is equal to one, it would essentially be like a pole,
an infinite pole that keeps going up forever and keeps going down forever
so it would never have a top or a bottom
but we slice that pole, with y plus z is equal to 2, to get where they intersect
we get our path C. We also have this vector field defined in this way